[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Ed welcome back to the podcast it is so
nice to see you again and thank you for
taking the time pleasure to be here I
thought that we could start with a few
of the points that I had specked out for
our first conversation and I want to
recommend to everyone if you haven't
heard our first conversation we cover a
lot of your bio a lot of your background
and we get into many many topics and
we'll create a short link so if you want
to listen to episode one just go to
tim.blog slash Thorp t-h-o-r-p and you
can listen to the first episode we'll
try not to have too much overlap in this
so let's start with
the topic of investing and specifically
the value of long-term thinking
end or the price of short-term thinking
and perhaps we can begin
there in any way that makes sense to you
well short-term thinking is uh what
benefited me when I first
investigated the markets there were
people who bought
a common stock warrants and held them
and when the warrants only had a couple
of years to go
they had much less value than they had
many years earlier but the people who
owned them didn't seem to recognize that
so these warrants were vastly overpriced
with around two years to go so I
discovered that and that's how I first
began to cash in with an edge in the
marketplace
could you define just for people who may
not have familiarity the common stock
warrants what is a common stock warrant
in this context common stock warrant is
a certificate issued by or a security
issued by a company typically a claim on
its own shares sometimes the companies
issue them on other companies and they
have shares in the treasury which they
will give up to you if the terms of the
warrant are realized and the warrant is
basically like what people know as a
call option today and they were the the
granddaddy of the whole listed call
option movement
so they led to very big changes in the
Securities industry
so you benefited from
short-term thinking or at least
awareness of short-term implications
what are some other examples of or maybe
combinations of short and long-term
thinking how would you suggest people
think about that here's an example from
Real Estate I used to have a friend that
I walked with quite a bit and he wanted
to sell his house around 1989 or 1990.
and at that time he could have sold his
house for uh I believe it was uh 3
million
and
he wanted to get three and a quarter
million and of course it was a housing
downturn and I said to him look get rid
of the house now use the money and
invest it
well he wouldn't do it it took 10 years
before he could sell his house and get
his price meanwhile this is short-term
thinking he wanted to hold out for a
little extra money
and he was willing to hold out a however
long it took and he didn't understand
that by holding out to the extra money
he was tying up his Capital he was
having an opportunity cost and he was
missing maybe a multiple of two or three
in the stock market over the next decade
so it cost him tremendously the quarter
million that he went for probably cost
him six or eight million
why do you think humans in general but
let's look at it within the sphere of
investing why people are generally so
poor at taking the longer term
perspective or at least considering
alternatives to that type of of
short-term Focus
well you know I I talked to all kinds of
people off and on I have through my life
and what I found is that most people
seem to be focused on what's immediately
around them and what's happening then
for instance I I know a very talented
woman who is a lawyer for a charitable
organization and she's been in this job
for over 20 years
and she is brilliant she does hard work
and she wants to do good but the
organization is terrible and in the way
they're managed so she's a she's a
victim in a high mental management
position and she needs to take her
talent and go somewhere else
but getting somebody to actually
make that uncomfortable transition is
very difficult even though for an
outsider it's totally obvious so a lot
of people when it's involving them they
can't see clearly
when it's involving one of their friends
or acquaintances they can generally see
a lot better or think they can
let's segue because I think this may be
complementary to what we've just been
discussing to numeracy
and perhaps we could begin with a
definition of terms but it strikes me
that this is one of the most valuable
topics that
I could ask your help in unpacking and
exploring where would you like to begin
I mean we could talk about numeracy
versus its opposite we could talk about
the fundamentals or basic numeracy where
would you like to begin a chapter of
conversing about numeracy I'm going to
go back to 1960.
when I was teaching at MIT and I went to
a wonderful lecture in their big rescue
Auditorium a public lecturer and it was
uh on the topic of two cultures and the
Scientific Revolution by a a well-known
Englishman named CP snow I think Charles
Percy snow but I'm not positive about
that and yeah there are a lot of
brilliant people on stage and what the
topic was was how many people really
accomplished people in the humanities
don't understand much about science
but there are a lot of first-class
scientists that are very good in the
humanities and lacking Elementary
numerical skills or comfort with it and
I'll put in that thought statistics and
probability and Game Theory and a whole
lot of other things that have become
much more important in the last many
decades
so
when you for example talk to an attorney
most often they're really good with
words but they make Elementary numerical
mistakes so I get a decimal place in the
wrong place and they won't realize it
that's one illustration of the sort of
things that happen
I think there are some fundamental
things that you miss if you read a news
article that's full of numbers the
numbers will often be presented to
ridiculous Precision like 63.8 percent
of people pull says such and such when
you think about the poll what does that
really mean it means somebody out there
copied down some stuff and did a
division and came up with 68.3 percent
but it doesn't mean that that poll
represents what people really believe it
might have been badly worded the sample
might be too small sample might have
been biased and so forth so 60 you might
read it if you're not a numeric person
and think that 68.3 is pretty good
Precision well the real answer ought to
be something like somewhere between
30 and 80 of people believe such and
such we think
I'm gonna put that way you can go on to
the next poll
another fundamental thing that people do
they mix up they don't understand the
difference between averages and the way
things are distributed in a population
an example to drive the point home there
are 100 people in a bar
and somebody knows who they are and says
gee the average net worth of the hundred
people in the bar is 100 000 each an
hour goes by one guy walks out of the
bar another guy walks in the guy checks
again he says the average net worth has
gone to a billion and a half
what happened well one guy walked out
and either Jeff Bezos or uh Elon Musk
walked in
so the average may tell you virtually
nothing about the distribution and we
deal with people often by thinking about
averages
instead of dealing with the individual
person and all their unique qualities
and where they might be in the
distribution
so when I meet somebody
I don't think about them as uh
be in any particular category I think
that
as far as I'm concerned they're my equal
and they know things I don't know I
probably know things they don't know too
but I can learn from them and I usually
try to hear what they have to say
instead of telling them what I have to
say this is today's an exception
well you are in the hot seats so I think
you I think you're certainly allowed to
answer more and say more than I do in
this context if we look at let's just
say the example you gave of how averages
can be misleading and I think people
listening even if they are
let's just say they are smart educated
but haven't had any particular training
in this domain
and they're unsure of how to train
themselves or develop this type of
awareness I'll make a recommendation
there's a book called bad science
by Ben goldacre who's a I believe he's a
UK physician
excellent Communicator as well and there
are a number of sections in this book
that I think are valuable for separating
for instance absolute versus relative
risk for instance you might see a
headline as you pointed on the newspaper
that says something like bananas double
your risk of colorectal cancer something
like that I'm making this up of course
and people might panic and stop eating
bananas but if the risk is one in a
billion and then it goes to two in a
billion the the risk itself and how you
should consider it in terms of your
lifestyle choices pretty minimal so
there are certain resources like that
book that I'm aware of but how would you
suggest someone train themselves to
become more numerate or are there other
basic concepts that you would suggest
they become aware of
there are two things that I would
encourage somebody to start with one of
them is to understand elementary
statistics and how it works nothing
complicated there's a series called
xiaom's outline it's a sort of uh like a
crib book for college courses and they
have a whole set of topics and one of
them is on statistics which I just gave
to my uh one of my daughters because she
was interested in this exact
conversation we're having how do you
spell shown I think it's s-c-h-a-u-m
got it
you'll find other simple College outline
books for statistics and what they do is
they get down to how to do it as opposed
to a lot of Fury and math formulas and
that sort of thing they should give you
a few basic formulas and they show you
how they work and that's really all you
need to get started and then if you're
curious and like it then you'll teach
yourself more if not what you have will
serve you well
that's the first thing the second thing
is
Elementary mental
calculations
people have their little
Apple phones or calculators and they can
find all kinds of things out on that but
if they hit the wrong key
they won't often know that what they've
gotten is garbage instead of the right
answer
and you can figure out a lot of things
in your head very easily if you get used
to it so I would learn how to multiply
small numbers in my head if I were
someone
and probably how to make other
calculations like in finance compound
growth calculations in your head are
very useful
and my book has a little section about
that called the rule 72. there that's
only the tip of the iceberg but if you
learn that and you like it you can go a
lot further and another pretty neat
thing that I've come across is uh if
somebody asks
you what what day of the week was Fourth
of July 1776 for example
you can figure it out in under a minute
in your head it turns out to be a
Thursday so
this is a well-known thing in the
literature I happen to stumble across it
for myself but that of thousands of
people figured all this out one before I
did but I find it's very handy and I
tend to remember
the calendar that way I don't actually
look at calendars but if somebody says
well you know what day does Christmas I
might say Sunday and after thinking
about it for a little while
but I don't have to go tap my calendar
and find out
do you know what that method is called
of determining the
these the day of the week for a specific
date I remember Michael Conway who was a
mathematics professor at Princeton could
do this also very very quickly but if I
if someone wanted to learn how to do
that how would you suggest they'd learn
how to do that or or is there a
particular name of the method there is
and uh
I'm trying to think
since was discovered Independent by many
people I'm not sure it has one name
but I'll just tell you briefly how it
works great for every date in a month
like uh well let's see
today is uh Tuesday June 14th 2022 so
14 is the day number that you assemble
there's each month has a number of its
own the number for June is four
where this comes from requires a little
investigation but the people who write
the Books explain it all to you you just
have to memorize how it works so you
have 12 month numbers and then every
year has a number that goes every year
of a particular Century has a number
that goes with it and as a way to figure
that out
pretty easily and then
every Century has a number
and so the calendar repeats every 400
years so you only need four century
numbers and then it rolls over and
repeats again so you add up all these
numbers you throw away sevens and see
what's left and if let's say a three is
left then it's a Wednesday if two is
left it's a Tuesday and so forth
this was made
pretty well known to people quite a long
time ago and a movie called rain man
right have you ever heard that movie I
have I have absolutely
he had two super skills one of them was
to
deliver the day of the week for any
calendar date
so we know how to do that
and the other one was two count cards of
blackjack and win and we know how to do
that
it was a mirror's chance my wife and I
were flying out on an airplane first
class
heading from I think LA to New York one
time we looked across the aisle and
there was Dustin Hoffman and his retinue
and I I thought I thought about I said
should I go over and tell them that I
know how to do all the rain man stuff no
don't bother him having a good time over
there
so let me mention a few things just for
people who want to explore this so the
first is we will find links to this
particular method and I'll put them in
the show notes at tim.blog slash Thorpe
I'll just put them with the first and
this now second episode I want to come
back to the rule of 72 in just a moment
because I think that'll be fun to to
just explain briefly for folks
rain man so the basis of Rayman is
someone named Kim Peak p-e-e-k
who also had some pretty astonishing
capabilities
he could read a book by flipping the
pages and the fixation points of his two
respective eyes would be on the two
respective pages in a given spread so he
had some some remarkable capabilities
but a lot of these capabilities as you
pointed out can be learned and learned
very quickly for instance if you want to
multiply a two digit number by 11 it can
get a little more complex than this but
if it's 34 times 11 it's 374 how do I
know because it's 3 plus 4 7 you stick
it in the middle and it's really
straightforward so you can develop these
these heuristics these these shorthand
methods and another I'll just I'll give
a reference to another guest Ed cook has
been on this podcast he is a or was a
competitive memory Champion so you could
memorize the shuffle deck of cards in 60
seconds or less that type of thing
and we talk about various methods and
mnemonics for memorizing long strings of
digits things like that so people can
check that out and I'll link to it in
the show notes Ed would you mind
elaborating on the rule of 72 sure
that's well known in real estate circles
if you want to know how long it takes
something to double how many years or
how many periods let's say you take the
interest rate per year let's say suppose
the interest rate is eight percent
if you divide 72 by 8 you get 9 and so
the doubling time for eight percent
compound growth is nine years
let's suppose that uh now with eight
percent the rules very accurate if you
use the numbers below eight percent the
doubling time turns out to be a little
shorter than the rule tells you and if
you use numbers above eight percent it
it gets a little longer the further away
you get above eight percent but it's
pretty good for first pass so for
instance uh
there's a house on the beach that I
looked at in 1970
4.
and
so that was uh
48 48 years ago can it be that long
yeah
your mental mathematics can be better
than mine I'll I'll accept 48. Okay so
you can use
rules like the rule 72 and their
offspring to use that time period to see
what the compound rate of growth was for
investing in that house
now the house now sells for 300 times
what it did then so you end up with a
pretty good rate of return When you
apply these rules anyhow the rule can be
used to calculate all kinds of stuff
like that and the easiest way to use it
is to calculate
doubling things
for instance
let's say that I invest in the stock
market and long term it goes up
10 a year
long term but it might be there might be
bad very bad periods and super good
periods that mix together but over a
very long time if it goes up 10 a year
then I can figure out how long it takes
to double and it'll be about 7.2 Years A
Little Less because we're higher the 10
is higher than eight percent
so the call let's call it seven plus a
small amount
what happens if you let it run for 100
years
well seven into a hundred is about 14.
that's 14 doublings
and one of the handy metal things that
you'll find is very useful is to know
what uh the doubling powers are 2 4 8 16
32 64 128 and so on and for
14 periods we're looking at about
well 10 doublings is about a thousand
and four more is about another 16 more
multiplying so you get up to around
sixteen thousand
times
so that's what the nominal growth at 10
over a century is sixteen thousand
multiple
so it tells you something about the
power of compounding
and why investing for the long term
really pays off
it also tells you why wasting money
really pays off in the negative way
it's a small example just at the low end
suppose a guy buys uh two packs of
cigarettes every day
maybe he spends I don't know what that
costs I don't pay attention to that but
let's say it's cost 15 for two packs
so if he put that 15 a day in the bank
and then every few months went and
bought an index fund in the stock market
with the money that he'd saved up in
maybe 60 years or so he might have half
a million dollars just because he gave
up the two pack a day habit you'd also
probably have seven more years of life
and you probably also feel a whole lot
better so this is just a little thing
that you can change with a huge
long-term impact
but short-term thinking said well you
know it makes me feel good I'll just
have another pack today another fact
tomorrow I'll get over it sometime
well let's come back to your friends
just to use uh I suppose it's not
entirely hypothetical it's a real case
but you are a friend who
could have sold his house for three
million but wanted to hold out for the
the 3.25 million or however much it was
and it ended up taking 10 years so
you're dealing with where we are dealing
with he or she is dealing with knowns
and unknowns in whichever path they take
in the decision tree whether it is
hoping for the extra 250k in an
unpredictable real estate market
but also dealing with unknowns in
putting let's just say the three million
into the stock market because as you
said there could be a bad stretch there
could be a really bad stretch of any
number of years
how would you if you had been having a
conversation with this friend and they
listened to your advice and they said
well I read a book on indexes and yes I
understand S P 500 and retained earnings
and over time X Y and Z over the long
term but what if I put it in and I have
five six seven bad years or however many
bad years how would you walk them
through
the decision process understanding that
we can't control outcomes necessarily
only the decision process but if they
voiced that they said I'm open to it but
I'm afraid that I'm going to put it in
and then the stock market's gonna crash
because there'll be some terrorist
attack or who knows what how would you
walk them through
making the best decision given the
knowns
I tell them that if you put it into
something risky that has good long-term
history and good long-term prospects
then you're going to get shaken up a lot
along the way so you have to be prepared
to hold for quite a long time to ride
out the speed bumps that you're going to
cross if you're not prepared for that
then you're going to make all kinds of
bad decisions along the way like getting
out of the bottom so
let me know first whether you're
prepared to do that or not and if you're
not you know uh you're on your own
what would you consider the minimally
viable
long term how many years in this
particular case if they said long term
sure what's long term for him he was a
50 or so yeah and he was still working
and he had other other assets
so
he didn't depend on what happened to
this money alone if it was down if the
market were down by 50 at some point
that wouldn't hurt him he could wait
some people can't wait and so those are
people that have to do things
differently if they don't have enough
capital I was listening to Thomas
picketty uh talking about his new book
which is very interesting and one of the
things he said was that
the poorer part of the country
maybe the lower half have insignificant
capital resources so if they're out of a
job they've got to get another job right
away because they're living paycheck to
paycheck and so they don't have the
luxury of being able to make better
choices they're being forced to make
immediate choices that aren't good
so this long-term investing advice is
for somebody who's not being forced to
make immediate choices and don't think
that they're going to be forced to do
that
so in the case of your friend 50 is
still working would you say the long
term that he should be prepared to
Buckle in for is 10 years 15 years
where would you put that number if you
had to Peg a a number just for the sake
of conversation if you were actually
having this conversation with with him
at the time okay I'm talking to a person
who's 45 years old I believe is that
right right now yeah I'm close to 45 yes
almost 45 pardon me almost 45
okay so I would say
look at the rest of your life how do you
project it I can live to be 80 90 100.
God I mean I I hope I live to be the the
and I know averages can be misleading
but let's just say the median
death age of males in my family seems to
be 85 to
88. so you've already outrun that I'm
hoping to outrun that so I'm aiming
higher but let's just for the sake of
arguments say 85.
well if you follow all kinds of healthy
habits which it seems to me that you do
and you're up on the latest things that
you believe actually have Merit not just
any fad
and you haven't had any major issues
it means you've probably got good genes
so far so good and you have economics
behind your economics
wealth is associated positively with
longevity and it's obvious why I mean
it's not fair but if somebody has
advantages they can avoid problems that
people that don't have those advantages
are forced to face so anyhow
I I would say that the odds if you're
reaching 100 are substantial
I I love this yes
I'm certainly I'm certainly aiming as
high as possible yeah so let's see what
was the question you just the question
was
if if we're personalizing this to me I
mean it may be a little strange to do so
but
I'm just imagining a conversation
between you and your friend who had the
opportunity to sell this home for 3
million
and you're talking about the the
different options and one being putting
the three million into let's just say a
low-cost Index Fund for the long term
and your friend turns around and says
I'm open to it but I know there are bad
stretches when you say long term how
many years should I be prepared to hold
for
I'm using that as as just a chance to
clarify for people who may be listening
what long-term could mean in terms of
absolute years when do you think you
might need the money in my case I don't
I I wouldn't need that money to pay the
bills you can let it run and run or not
I could now I mean this gets into some
this gets into varied terrain just
because
I think in terms of not just lifespan
but also Health span so am I hoping to
build that capital and then uh let's say
whether it's gift to family or give to
charity
do I want to enjoy it in some fashion
while I am still physically capable and
able to be out and about and fully
capable mentally and physically I mean
these are certain questions that that
come to mind for me as well but the the
truth is I would not I would not need to
liquidate that to pay the bills yeah if
you can let it grow to some extent not
spend it down then you have the luxury
of being able to invest for a very long
time
but if if you need to spend on Capital
take a personal priority has no sources
of income but Social Security and
they've got a million dollar retirement
fund and they're going to live another
20 to 30 years maybe
they've got to be pretty careful yeah
assume they're not able to or willing to
work anymore
and so somebody like that needs a plan
that will
caused the money to last as long as
possible while they're still alive and
take care of them but also they need to
be able to spend at a rate that gives
them a decent life so that's a tricky
tricky trade-off everybody's different
I would say that the more pressure there
is in which you might have to spend
down your Capital at some Future Point
probably the less likely you are to try
to become a long-term investor in
something that's quite risky
there's no one thing that's going to
satisfy everybody it's a well-known
problem in financial economics the
lifetime consumption problem but my view
is if you can get ahead enough so you
have enough Capital so you're
comfortable then this problem mostly
goes away you just stick it in for the
long run at a high rate of return and
let it go and you spend some of it as
time goes by
but you don't have to spend so much as
to really eat into it hourly
so let me pause for just a moment to
mention and ask a few things so the
first is the shelms outline of
Statistics is spelled exactly as you
said
s-c-h-a-u-m apostrophe s and covers any
number of subjects so I'm excited to dig
into that someone very close to me is
actually going to be taking statistics
in grad school soon and they're very
intimidated so this this will be ordered
today my question for you is to develop
more numeracy and basic familiarity with
probabilities slash statistics
something that comes to mind for me and
this is from Recently interviewing a
poker player is that perhaps by
encouraging people to play poker or
Blackjack you could enable them to
absorb some of these principles while
having fun or doing something that has
an objective outside of just becoming
numerate are there any approaches like
that or that come to mind that you might
suggest to people who would like to
absorb
and cultivate some of
these principles and numeracy
aside from reading a book on statistics
there are other games other
activities anything that comes to mind
there's a mathematician out at in the
Claremont colleges named Arthur Benjamin
and I think he has a book called
mathematic mathematic and he also has a
course on the Great Courses I don't know
I haven't followed the Great Courses for
a while but I've seen that he has such a
course and you can learn how to do a lot
of math in your head by
looking at this stuff wonderful
mathemagic Arthur Benjamin all right I
will link to all of that what I thought
we might do next we were talking about a
a fairly
common and simple example of your friend
with the real estate decision
we discussed in our last conversation
a number of things related to hedge
funds and there were questions around
Citadel and
listeners wanted to know how one might
get an edge and hedge fund investing
what would you like to say to that or
any comments you'd like to to add to
satisfy some of those books
the hedge fund world has gotten very big
when I was in it they're only when I
first started they're only a couple
hundred hedge funds and
a hedge fund
in its original usage meant a private
limited partnership
that invests in typically Financial
products and it could be things like
real estate
loans equities Commodities very
wide-ranging it's kind of a catch-all
for private limited investment
partnership the typical structure is
that
there are a group of limited partners
there could be 100 200 of them and a
managing General partner and the limiter
Partners just collect whatever returns
they get and the managing General
partner charges a fee typically so much
per year plus a percent of the returns
so that that's the basic structure and
Citadel that I talked about last time
isn't such a thing it is a collection of
businesses and
only one part of those businesses is
the private limited investment fund that
I happened to be a limited partner in so
just a clarification on that
now
the asset class of hedge funds is very
large
it's now about three trillion dollars
which is like two percent of the entire
net worth of the United States
and it has perhaps ten thousand or so
hedge funds in it some of them very
large like your guest Ray dalio
or like Citadel and then they they range
in size all the way down from the
multi-billion dollar ones down to a few
million dollars and they often start at
a small level like that it's pretty hard
to run one now and start it up because
of all the costs if it's less than a few
million dollars
so the hedge fund World used to be a
much better place for individuals to
invest now it's better for institutions
I'll give you an illustration
the hedge fund that I was in for 30 or
so years in the hedge fund part of
Citadel they
in the first
I don't know 17 years or so
we were making 20 plus percent
annualized not to us after all the fees
that's incredible it was incredible now
it wasn't so good for me because I was
taxable so I might be getting uh 14
percent
35 combined state federal tax rate but
then for an institution it was a
fabulous uh tax exempt institution like
a university endowment fund and then
maybe from 2008 to 2015 returns were
somewhat less I I don't remember the
exact numbers but let's say they were uh
14 and now I'm in the 50 tax bracket
taxes went up
so I'm only getting seven percent
so the market long term is riskier but
it's going to give me 10 and I don't
have to do any work uh all I do is uh
invest once I don't do any paperwork
that sort of thing
and so at that point for me the Market's
probably a better choice but for the tax
exemption investor they're still getting
14 It's a Wonderful choice so that's
sort of how the head formed World
changed for the really good hedge funds
for the not so good ones
they as a group have gotten sort of less
and less attractive for people
now you might say who should invest in
hedge funds today I would say wealthy
tax exempt investors
whether they be individuals or
institutions they might say well how
many of my listeners have that pedigree
maybe not very many but when you think
about all the people who are listening
to this a lot of them are probably on
the boards of
tax-exempt entities like the university
endowment funds
and so they can advise them if they want
to learn about this sort of thing and
see whether some of these hedge funds
are good choices
I might say the collection of all hedge
funds together taken as a pool
are not attractive about that as if
there were an index a cap weighted index
to fetch funds it would not be an
attractive asset class anymore in my
opinion but if there are there are
exceptions like the Citadel operation
yeah well I shouldn't I said it all like
the hedge fund part of Citadel
the whole business is is beyond me it's
you know it's like I invested in the
Amazon bookstore initially and Amazon
has all these other things I don't have
anything to do with all the other things
as a passive investor I'm still invested
in the bookstore
I'll also mention just in passing that
if you were to look at the venture
capital
industry let's call it as a whole it
would make a terrible index they tend if
you were to average it all out it would
it would perform under the market more
times than not but there are there are
standouts I wanted to recommend two
books and if you have any opinions on
these actually I suppose it's more of an
author recommendation than anything else
but for people who want to gain some
familiarity with the history of hedge
funds and what constitutes a hedge fund
in other words a fund that has Hedges
versus those that are say unidirectional
but nonetheless call themselves hedge
funds Etc there's a book called more
money than God by Sebastian malaby that
I found very entertaining and he has
written a new book which I have not read
I believe it's called the power law
which really delves into venture capital
and there are some striking similarities
so I will I will just leave those two
aside
Ed I would love to ask you next about a
few books that I have here in front of
me the titles of that is that
we're in some notes I had for our last
conversation and it relates to expert
advice predictions and more but there is
a book here which I've not read but I've
heard of before called extraordinary
popular delusions and The Madness of
crowds is this a book that you would
recommend yes
it was originally written I think back
in 1851
I forget who the author is I the name
Charles McKay comes to mind but I don't
know if that's the publisher of the
author and uh
you're finding out now I am you know The
Madness of crowds no you got it Charles
McKay extraordinary popular delusions
and The Madness of crowds by Charles
McKay
m-a-c-k-a-y and I'll say this about it
it's not wholly accurate I've seen the
critiques and Corrections of it but it's
a great read and it gives you the flavor
of
crowd Madness it might be a good reading
for people who are involved in
cryptocurrency now for instance
or in a GameStop
[Laughter]
and I I will also just mention for folks
that there is a looks like a decent
Wikipedia page
for this book which covers some of the
main tenets and anecdotes and stories
within it it was first published in
1841. what would you hope people to get
out of this let's just say that they are
in the midst of buying and selling
cryptocurrency and they say this Ed
Thorpe seems like a very bright guy I'm
going to take his advice and read this
book what would you help them to gain
from reading this book
I think the first fundamental thing is
if everybody's heard about it already
there's
historically at least no reason to
believe that you have any kind of edge
makes sense you're basically rolling
dive
or buying lottery tickets and
just as in The Gambler casinos where a
person does where most people do not
have an edge you hear stories about
lucky winners metros and more people who
want to play but if you look at all of
them as a group including the good
players who actually have an edge if you
look at all of them as a group
they lose
and that's how the casinos survived
after they didn't lose as a group the
casinos wouldn't be there
right
well let's let's segue
off to a slightly well completely
different subject area which is
physical and mental Fitness we we
covered some of this in our last
conversation but there's certainly more
specifics that we can explore here so
just just to ensure I'm doing my fact
checking are you still 89 years of age
or have you have you already turned a
new a new birthday still 89 but getting
close
all right so I will reiterate for people
who didn't hear the first episode you
look like you're 60. it is remarkable uh
certainly something to Aspire to and
removes any excuses I might have and
I have notes in front of me with a
number of things that I would love to
discuss the the first is
developing awareness and I I have a note
here about recording or recording your
weight
what is your suggestion for people and
is this something that you have done
yourself
yes first of all I had a relative who
was significantly overweight and he he
wished to lose weight
and so I said the first thing you do
I'm not going to tell you what to eat or
how to eat or anything else the first
thing you do is you get on a scale every
morning
and you write down the date and how much
you wait
and just observe that number and do that
day after day
well turned out he didn't really want to
lose weight and so after a while he
stopped doing this and so I got after
him to do it again for a while and then
he quit again and his weight would go
down and bounce back up and go down and
bounce back up but when he was writing
it down it seemed to alter his behavior
and he would his weight would slowly
drift downward
so
I've made a habit myself of getting on
the scale maybe not every morning
because I don't need to anymore but for
a long time I'd get on every morning and
just observe what I weighed and I've
been pretty well bracketed between 151
and about 158 for as long as I can
remember
and if I get near 158 I
I say well you know I don't need that
dessert tonight or that beer we'll have
it some other time
or how about a great big healthy salad
today instead of a burger
and it's enough to shift me down and
then I have another little thing that I
check you know they're there's a
simplistic notion of apples and pears in
people
I don't know have you heard about this
one I have an apple is somebody that
tends toward getting a big pot belly
when they gain weight
and I come from a family of apples
and this is not healthy because you get
all this fat around your internal organs
so one of the things I put on my list
early was never
get that Potbelly so all I have to do is
I can look down if I see anything that
isn't flat down there I know I weigh too
much
that's another awareness needs to change
things those two feedbacks are more than
enough to control my weight for a
lifetime and I really have to use them
but anyhow I would say that a person can
develop their own feedbacks whatever
those are and use them and measurement
is important because you want facts on
which to base what you do instead of
hopes beliefs wishes so on
I remember a t-shirt that I was given a
long time ago by the director James
Cameron it was actually an original
staff shirt
for the film Avatar and the very top of
it said hope is not a strategy I wish I
liked which I liked quite a lot and
you're weighing just to get specific is
before breakfast and without clothes or
what you would recommend is that is that
accurate I do two things
when that's convenient I do that when
it's not convenient
I just happened to go to the scale maybe
before a shower in the middle of the day
and I weigh myself and put that down as
a little side fact and of course I'm
going to weigh more in the middle of the
day than I did first thing in the
morning so I know that
so maybe I weigh 152 in the morning but
when I put my little side thing down I
might say at 3 P.M I say 154 and a half
so I know that roughly speaking about
each third of the day correspond to each
possible meal I gain about one pound
so I can mentally correct back to the
beginning of the day
I don't have to weigh myself every
morning if it's not convenient
if I get other feedback right absolutely
the whole thing about health and fitness
as I see it is
you want to do things that are
preventative
and you want to make sure you're not
missing something important
because it's the things you miss that
are going to do more damage than the
positive things
are to save you I mean you can work out
and be fit and have high aerobics and so
on but if you're not going in for a
routine colonoscopies and skin cancer
injections and so on you're leaving a
big risk factor open for yourself
so you've got to try to get rid of the
risks that uh you can cover
do you have a checklist for yourself or
how do you ensure that you are not
missing
gaps or blind spots
I think about it and I talk to people
and I pick up information all over my my
list expands you know there's a there's
a lot of a lot of topics on the list
there's a physical fitness of various
kinds there is mental health
there's uh supplements which I don't
take much of because the evidence isn't
strong enough in my mind for them other
people will disagree but I'm not heavy
on supplements only if I think they've
really been proven one thing that I've I
found that really worked well was uh
bone supplements
and I was able to reverse osteopenia and
turn it into
excess bone after several years
bone supplements meaning say calcium
magnesium K2 Blends things of that type
yeah
I have a few bullet points that I would
love to hear you expand on and actually
before I get to that I should say that
it is incredible how much behavioral
change can subconsciously seep into
someone's life also consciously but
I I find the subconscious side
especially interesting if they simply
begin to measure whether it's body
weight or body composition which is
partially why
self-directed observational studies or
at home
uh-huh clinical trials or experiments
are so difficult
to design well because you can you can
say to someone all right you're going to
follow the Mediterranean diet keep all
of your other variables the same don't
change anything else but rarely is that
going to be the case
so that's just a side note
one more factoid for folks Mr Rogers was
also very
diligent about weighing his body I think
it was every day when he swam and his
magic number was 143 he tended to stay
within a few pounds of 143. there are a
few bullets here I would love to hear
you expand on the first is
limit alcohol to a total of a few drinks
a week so this
makes sense to me do you drink alcohol
yourself if so what do you drink I
typically drink
maybe a half a beer
three or four times a week and maybe
when I have company a glass of or two of
wine
that's pretty much it
and I think it's too much
you think that's too much yeah
do you have a favorite beer or favorite
wine that you tend to consume if if
you're rationing in that way well I
never drank beer until a few years ago
but we went over to Ireland and we
visited the Guinness Brewery which has a
long colorful history really interesting
and the stuff was really great so I
I did not see that coming wow all right
so you picked up beer a few years ago so
the 85 86 something like that yeah I
love that so I I probably need to go the
the in the opposite direction with some
of my alcohol consumption for sure there
are no breweries yeah yeah I I'm
actually pretty good these days my
girlfriend doesn't drink very much at
all and she's like 20 pounds so we we
tend not to drink too much one is
reduced stress now this is also
something that at face value I think
will make sense to a lot of people
but begs the question of specifics how
do you reduce stress what have you done
to reduce stress in your life that
you've found to have a meaningful impact
one thing that really works for me is
listening to music
and also another thing is just going for
walks and thinking about whatever my
mind just kind of runs free and I'll
maybe uh maybe after this conversation
I'll go for an hour walk and I'll think
about the things we said and oh well I
wish I said but forgot so on or
is there a type of music that you
gravitate towards I happen to like
classical but I also like guitar and I
like a lot of old songs and uh music
from the movies it reminds me of
pleasant times I've had
I like stock Jazz too I do too I've
developed a
a real predilection and
this eagerness to consume more Jazz and
Blues I'm not sure maybe it's my
maybe my proximity to a lot of that in
Austin and recently spent time in New
Orleans but I'm on the same page with
those there's there's a bullet here
avoid unnecessary risks
could you expand on that what type of
risks have you trained yourself to avoid
well but really everywhere so
I have a laundry list of them that gets
longer and longer as I think about them
more here's a for instance kovid
good current example
people are wandering around now mostly
without masks and they're acting like
it's over
but I don't see any reason to catch it
and one of them it's not going to do any
good if I do catch it especially being
89 high risk group the death rate there
is probably close to 20 percent in the
89 year old category now I'm healthier
and I probably have better medical
access than most people so it might be
only two or three percent for me
but that's too big so I try to be
careful avoid crowds no commercial
travel unless it's forced upon me and
you just can't avoid it
the key thing is don't share air
with people that might possibly be ill
with covid and some of them don't know
it
so anyhow that that's an avoidable a
largely avoidable risk if you're willing
to
limit your activities
now what I'm hoping is that we'll have a
broad spectrum antiviral that will allow
us to get a shot and put an end to all
this but government seems very slow in
getting its act together
and that's it's not telling how long
it's going to be that's one risk
another one is travel
let's say that I want to go from
Orange County California to New York
City
I could fly out of Orange County airport
non-stop to Newark and take somewhat
less convenient for me flight
or I could I could connect
a land somewhere take off again on the
way a so-called direct flight but it's
not Non-Stop
or I could go to LAX and get all kinds
of flights with uh much greater time
ranges
if I go to LAX I'm going to spend
40 plus miles in a car
two ways
the risk of driving in a car is
roughly 100 times per mile but it is
flying an airplane
which is a gigantic difference
now airplane risk
but most of the risk is take off and
landed so I won't take a direct flight
if I can help it because there are more
takeoffs than Landings so my Optimum is
to go to Orange County
take a somewhat less convenient flight
avoid takeoffs and landings and so
there's a small risk reduction you might
say well
how much risk reduction is there
it's maybe you know a chance in a
Million but with little thinking I can
get rid of it
here's another example I don't know if
we
talked about this before or not it was
about uh
uh sorry I heard by Benjamin Stein on
his program he he is the son of
herbertstein famous economist and
Benjamin Stein himself is Economist but
also he's partly comedian
on purpose
he and uh Milton Friedman a well-known
name were walking in New York City and
they came they came to one of these
cross streets where the light was red
but didn't seem like anybody was going
back and forth
so Benjamin Stein stepped off the curb
and Milton Friedman said Benji wait a
minute
and Benjamin Stein said no it's safe to
go and Milton Friedman said uh you know
Benji
probably it is but
maybe it isn't why should I risk the
rest of my life to save 20 seconds
and that's the sort of decision that a
lot of people don't make they'll they'll
run that red light because they can just
barely get through
once in a while one of them gets T-boned
so the risk everywhere like this and you
can if you think about them a little bit
and make it a habit you get rid of piles
of them there's a book called The
Unthinkable I think by Amanda Ripley
and
she talks about horrible things that
people horrible situations people have
found themselves in for example the Twin
Towers in 2001.
and
people made various decisions some of
which saved their lives others caused
people to lose their lives so she has uh
three steps denial where this can't be
happening The Liberation where you say
well you know it is happening what am I
going to do
and then there's decision okay I'm gonna
do something now
so I I kind of like a little I'm a
little more uh proactive I say that
there's a for me there's awareness
and then there's analysis
and then there's action
so what what kinds of things could
happen well besides the Twin Towers you
might find yourself in a burning theater
you might find uh your building shaking
from an earthquake
you might see a
we hope none of these things happen you
might see the sky light up like a
thousand suns
and you figure out that uh there's been
a nuclear detonation
so multiple things or a huge volcanic
explosion somewhere or a tidal wave you
know a million won very remote things
but then there are things in everyday
life
somebody starts shooting here in the
crowd
you have riddle time to decide what to
do I mean what I've dropped to the
ground first thing and then figure out
what to do next
because you're a small Target
and then see how you can help
but people have these things suddenly
thrust upon them and if you have some
thought about how you'd act in some of
those things like I know what I do in my
high-rise office building if there was
an earthquake if you have some idea of
how you'd act ahead of time it helps
prepare you so that you can uh probably
have a better chance of coming out of it
with
less loss or damage
so
that's another approach for a big risk
the sort of things most people don't
like to think about and prefer think
about healthy things
you know it's it's having been through a
number of
natural disasters and also crisis
situations for instance in Austin Texas
but also in San Francisco
it is always astonishing to me and maybe
I just have a healthy sometimes
unhealthy degree of paranoia about low
probability events but
if you look at even recent history like
the Loma Prieta earthquakes in San
Francisco or you look at the freezes in
Austin that
paralyze the city prevented
transport trucks from delivering Goods
ended up disrupting water supply I am
amazed how few people have a week or two
worth of backup water
it's just an example of something that
you can remedy with a few hundred
dollars you know less than they spend on
a given weekend at restaurants
but just how few people
have that type of contingency planned
for even after they have had a really
close call so I remember
in Austin deep freeze lasts a week and I
had some involvement during this entire
thing with a sort of Disaster Response
and it was pure luck that we had the
thaw when we did if it had lasted
another day or two it would have been
catastrophic in terms of lives lost for
a number of reasons
but even after that happened
I spoke with a number of acquaintances
who had been in Dire Straits and I asked
them if they had bought back up water
and a few other things and they said no
that was a one in a hundred years type
of storm that'll never happen again
now this is puzzling
are there any other risks from say an
exercise perspective or a behavioral
perspective a day-to-day kind of
week-to-week perspective that you have
removed by doing this type of analysis
for yourself things that you used to do
that you no longer do
yeah I used to run on roads when I was
training
and I soon changed that because I read
about what the statistics were for
runners being hit by cars on roads even
if you run on the side in the bike pass
it's too much risk so I went off-road
and now when I walk it's the same thing
I don't walk on roads like I walk off
road
except enough a community where there's
basically no act no action and I can see
and hear everything
what is the age guessing experiment oh
yeah that was a funny thing
about
I think when I was about 82 or so people
kept saying gee these looks like you're
60. I said well that's very flattering
but uh you know it's nice to hear I
wonder how much truth there is in this
so can I measure this has this got any
fact behind it
so what I decided to do was
approach strangers at convenient places
like a waiter in a restaurant where I'd
never eaten before
and I'd say
I have five dollars here I'd like you to
answer
a question about me assuming you know
nothing about me
and if you
are close I'll give you the five dollars
and the question was how old am I uh
within five years
so I did this with a wide range of
people about 20 people all together over
several months just to entertain myself
and I had a lot of fun with it hi in one
restaurant
when somebody guessed uh like 53 I said
no and they said well my friend wants to
guess and I said friend do you want to
go higher or lower
so friends thought a while I think they
went higher so they said something like
uh 65 or so and I said no and I tried
again 75 no
but one one woman came pretty close she
was uh an old lady and senior citizens
Library she was about 83.
and
I asked her the same question and she
looked at me and she said I think you're
about 72. that's enough you know five
years and then I said to her see that
kid walking along there how old do you
think he is kid is about 18 or 20. she
said I think about 40.
the meat the mean was in the 50s then
but but that was several years ago
[Laughter]
well I mean that just sounds like a fun
game to play also it's very entertaining
and you can play with any other kind of
question too
and it strikes me that you have
developed an ability and perhaps this is
somewhat innate as well but to think for
yourself and to attempt to start from
first principles whenever possible I'd
love to pick up on a thread that I was
hoping to explore last time which is
other directed versus Inter directed and
there's another book title I believe
it's a book called The Lonely crowd Yeah
by David reesman that's right that's
right could you speak to this and
provide
any any elaboration that you think is is
helpful and if there are any resources
or approaches that you might suggest to
people who want to become more
interdirected
first of all the lonely crowd it
basically explores the idea of people
who are quote interdirected you'd call
them maybe introverts but that's not
quite it's not quite the same thing and
people who are other directed who tend
to overlap with extroverts and other
directed people tend to guess their
Direction on their values and their
gratification from the people around
them
so they tend to do they tend to conform
and they tend to go with fads and they
tend to go with the majority vote on
things and interdirected people tend to
be more
self-deciding about things they tend to
be more associated with the introverts
but not exclusively there are a lot of
I'll call them interdirected extroverts
they by interdirector I think of
yourself as having your own independent
moral and ethical compass and kind of
set of rules for living and guiding
yourself and another directed person
tends to pick those up from others
others basically indicate to them what
the right things to do are and what the
wrong things to do are
so it's an interesting line of thought
there's a way to get into this a little
bit
there's uh a book
trying to think the name of it it is
a personality typing
scheme started by a mother and daughter
and they have four major personality
Dimensions one is introvert extrovert
the next is
sensing versus oh is this Myers-Briggs
yes it is that's it thank you right the
Myers-Briggs type indicator yes and so
that is I think very useful even though
it's simplicity
it kind of breaks people down into 16
major categories depending on
Which choice they are in each of four
dimensions two times two times two times
two and then it gives you a general
description of a pure type like intj as
a pure type and so the general
description will be a scientist slash
Mastermind or something like that and uh
estp is promoter
so all kinds of things come with
promoter
but e is extrovert s is sensing which
means more
thinking and
more like I guess more sensitive to the
people around you and uh how they do
things and how they act you can read
them
so if you look at these categories you
realize that they individual people
aren't in aren't any one of these 16
types but if you run into a person
you'll often find that one of them is
very much like one of those 16 types and
when you find that out you can
understand a lot of things about them
very quickly
sometimes will be a mixture of two of
the 16 types and again it's not too hard
to figure out a lot of things about them
and if you type yourself and you're
anywhere near one of the 16 pure types
you will be your hair will stand on the
back of your head to the extent each
either of us have any here
you have a lot more hair than I do
I've been growing it and growing it so
it's incredible sometimes the insights
that you're suddenly get into somebody
that you know you say oh the this kind
of person they're they're artistic and
artistic has these things that go with
it all the time almost
so you learn quite a bit quickly about
people not everything and you run the
risk of stereotyping
taking a prototype from a group and
using that to represent everybody in the
group and of course there's a huge
spread among the people in the group
what we talked about before about
averages and distributions the same idea
but anyhow it's a useful introduction to
thinking about other people and
realizing they're different from you
they're not better they're not worse if
they're a different type they're just
different and you need to try to
understand
where they're coming from and it helps
one do that a bit so I'd recommend that
as a kind of psychology introduction to
understanding people better what is your
type
uh science
mostly intj I did the typing a long time
ago for myersberg and I'm also an intj
oh this is not to imply I have your
personality or skill set but well that
shows you how different people in
category can be yeah and of course we're
not we're not pure either
you know we're 90 high and or something
like that or eighty percent whatever
happens to be instead of 100 percent
I think I'm uh it's you know introverted
intuitive thinking judging I'm probably
99 judging which I'm not sure always
helps me
uh that's a joke it's a joke but
the lonely crowd just to pick up on that
what is the
the takeaway or what would you hope
people
in an overarching way to glean from the
lonely crowd is it is it the personality
differentiation that you're describing
along the lines of a Myers-Briggs or is
there more to that book that you would
hope people would notice
I think the biggest takeaway for me was
simply the notion that people who are
quote other directors unquote which
means that they pick up the cues about
what to do and how to behave and what's
good and what's bad from the crowd those
people are kind of afloat without a
compass and it's harder to be that kind
of person and those people are lonely
because they don't really have anything
inside that helps them
feel a sense of worth
and helps them make decisions that are
clear-cut and that they feel like they
can really count upon
so they're kind of a drift away
yeah I'd love to tie two things together
because I'm I always wonder for myself
how does one develop
this is a skill as opposed to an inborn
attribute let's say or is it developable
right if I want to learn to swim I can
improve my stroke but I'm never going to
have the same
phenotype as Michael Phelps right I'm
just not going to have these these crazy
anomalous flipper feat for instance with
Hyper range of motion it's just not
going to happen so in the case of the
Lonely crowd and developing an inner
Compass I want to tie that back to
numeracy because I find that if someone
learns how to
say scrutinized studies or
journalists who try to interpret studies
it is an incredibly liberating and
confidence building because they no
longer feel entirely dependent on some
high priesthood of interpreters to tell
them how to think or to to tell them how
to
digest or metabolize data they can
actually go straight to the source so I
I do feel like developing a basic basic
basic understanding of probabilities and
statistics a very basic ability to do a
handful of mental calculations a very
basic ability to read a study for
oneself and I think all three of those
check boxes could be checked in a in a
single month I think with
you know a few hours a week
for a few weeks you could make an
incredible amount of Headway
for me that seems to correspond to
people who are more
internally directed I don't know if that
resonates at all for you but I I did
want to at least from my experience tie
those two things together it resonates
fully with me
yeah
so I'll add some some more resources in
addition to those that you mentioned
into the show notes for this episode so
people can pick up on that and people
will harangue me if I don't follow up on
one comment that you made which was I've
been growing and growing my hair so how
does an 89 year old grow and grow their
hair
well I I stumbled into some one thing
accidentally which may or may not work
for everybody it only applies to Men by
the way
there is a drug called finasteride
or post Garden have you have you heard
of this drug
I have if you have an enlarged prostate
which most older men tend to get
you want to keep that thing from getting
larger and larger because it squashes
other things down there like your
bladder for example so you have to go to
the bathroom more often if you have a
huge prostate I've often from the Opera
gone into
the restroom and intermission and these
guys are standing there for five minutes
I know they have enlarged prostates so
slowing the growth of your prostate it's
a good thing so if finasteride does that
however it just so happens that it also
promotes hair growth and it's the best
thing I've ever heard of for promote a
hair growth it doesn't promote massive
hair growth but it's noticeable and it
also causes you to retain your hair so I
noticed more hair right away when I
started taking it how long have you been
taking it
probably 20 years
20 years do you have much baldness in
your family my father was involved okay
all right you had male pattern baldness
see my father is not bald but and my mom
is not bald but I certainly at this
point involved maybe I'll pick up the
finasteride for people wondering also if
finasteride is also sold as propitious
as well known as Propecia as well it's a
five Alpha reductase inhibitor I think
you get a higher dose if you get
finasteride prescribed I almost wrote it
up and I'm pretty sure that's true
because I knew about the
over-the-counter versions but they were
maybe a fifth as strong at the time I
checked that makes sense and of course
I'll just mention because it's a good
idea speak to your doctor neither of us
are doctors we don't play them on the
Internet so please speak with your
medical professional there are possible
side effects with this and and most
drugs absolutely Pro scar finasteride
look it up Good Wikipedia entry
is there anything else that you would
like to mention on the health side of
things and we can potentially and we can
we can discuss this another time but
look at adding something on Tim not blog
that might outline some of this in
Greater detail but is there anything
else that you think is uh we would be
remiss not to mention or that we should
include in the conversation of Health
and Longevity I think we're pretty well
confident from my standpoint
yeah I think we've covered quite a bit
there's really one more thing that I
have highlighted here that I'd love to
cure you
expand on and that is
using scrap time
I've never seen this expression before
although I can sort of Intuit what it
might mean
how do you use scrap time or recommend
people use scrap time and what is that I
just made it up for this conversation oh
you did great because I was thinking
about things
perfect this is an exclusive a worldwide
exclusive
well a lot of people complain that
they're bored
or they get impatient when they're stuck
somewhere for example let's say I'm at
at a long traffic light I happen to have
to drive through about three or four two
minute traffic lights sometimes they
catch me sometimes they don't this is a
couple days a week I go in for a few
hours to my office
so whenever the traffic lights sitting
there what do I do I could say I wish
this light would change or maybe I could
maybe I should have run that light no I
know I don't do that
instead you know I've got a couple of
minutes here I can do whatever I want
well my next little stiff today why
don't I do a few neck exercises or a few
shoulder shrugs or whatever and by the
time I'm bound to that the two minutes
is gone I'm ready to go to the next
traffic light so the scrap time turns
out to be a payoff rather than a
negative and I don't care about the
incredit lights not at all or a doctor's
office like going to the doctor's office
they say well we were going to take you
10 30 but uh there's been a delay the
doctor had to do an operation he won't
be here for a while he'll be back at 11.
if I don't have something else scheduled
I say okay fine if I have anything on my
phone I do that I use the scrap top if I
run out of stuff like that I try to get
some exercise in some stretches some
limbering up and so on and it's amazing
when I start doing that they take me in
a lot quicker than they would otherwise
because everybody knows this guy's been
forced to wait and wait and wait it's
not why I do it I try to do it as subtly
as possible
but uh or I'm sitting there in the uh
the doctor's room number seven waiting
for him to show up same thing more scrap
time
I can get 10 or 15 minutes I like raises
push-ups all that kind of stuff in
you know another Advantage I can imagine
is that they see you doing all this and
they're like
this patient is is scaring the other
patients we have to get him through the
system as quickly as possible
they move you along Ed I'd love to know
and if if there's no answer that comes
readily to mind that's fine as well but
I'm 45 and I'm wondering we're roughly
45.
after some thinking you know I am
roughly at the the midpoint to my my
next Target which is to get to your age
and then from there to 120 or who knows
where you know by then the world will
have changed a lot and your odds will be
a lot better one can help a Boy Can
Dream so I I hope that is the case and
that we're not living in some dystopian
future where no one has any reproductive
health so I am I am hoping for the the
upside case let's assume that is true
what are some of the
the new beliefs or changes in beliefs
that most positively impacted your
second half
and of course this is self-serving and
it's it's possibly a hard question but
how did your thinking or priority or
beliefs change kind of after the after
the midpoint
that you think retrospectively looking
at it have most benefited you or those
around you
I started running
probably when I was about 40 just a mile
or so uh on a Saturday and then I as we
talked about last time I built it up
then I started actually running
marathons when I was 47. so I got into
running very late but uh marathoning
taught me quite a bit about life in a
way because I began to send myself you
know life is a lot like running a
marathon and if you look at it that way
here I am at that age then back in uh
roughly around 50. here I am at the
midpoint
perhaps of a marathon so if you're
running a marathon you don't Sprint
because you'll burn yourself out early
you are careful enough to step in
potholes there are all kinds of other
things that you need to take care of in
order to get to the finish line and you
eventually learn
some of us learn how to get through the
wall without there being a wall anymore
which took it took me seven marathons to
figure that one out
and
so I thought to myself well
the same thing about light you if you
plan ahead you can avoid a lot of
problems that sink other people
knee replacements
are clogging up
catching diseases because you don't do
proper vaccination
going to countries where there are
horrible diseases to catch in the first
place and you can't protect yourself
fully maybe that sort of thing so
thinking long term is one thing that
running a marathon teaches
us
and so I tend to think long term anyhow
but that was a great reinforcement
in the last say five to ten years is
there anything you've profoundly changed
your mind about
or it could be recently I don't need to
put a time frame on it
to me the value of
being around good people
and not being around a few bad people is
uh much higher than it ever was before
and the people in my life I've consider
the most important and my actions with
good people the most important thing you
know I enjoy other things but I think at
this age
you've basically done most of the stuff
that you're going to do of any general
broad significance and so it's a time to
reflect and to think about life and
enjoy it and if you have any if one has
any wisdom to assure it to some extent
hmm
well you see him as sharp and as Lively
as ever as far as as far as I can tell I
mean you you certainly have more
Vitality however I know that's a bit of
a maybe an italicized word but life
force than a lot of the 40-somethings I
know so whatever you're doing keep keep
doing it and is there anything else Ed
that you'd like to add before we
bring this conversation to a close
hmm I think
an important thing for everyone is to
think about
the world and society as
us instead of me
and to try to act that way
and to think longer term think about
how the things one does affects
the people around not only right away
but down through the years and it might
seem like it doesn't matter but it does
in a way and a lot of these things will
that you make better now
for the future will actually benefit us
a lot sooner than you might think
otherwise
pollution for example you know climate
change is is coming along that's coming
along pretty fast
and people might say well what do I care
about what happens 50 years from now
but it's happening increments it'll be a
little worse next year and a little
worse the year after and so on you might
not want to be around when it's really
bad 50 or 100 years from now but you
might not care because
you're only going to be alive another 10
years let's say if you're a pretty old
person
but still
these things come along
sometimes faster than you think and in
ways that you don't expect and so it's
wise I think to just try to make the
world a better place in any way you can
even though you might not reap all the
benefits
yeah here here I
I recall a conversation a friend had
with an engineer I won't name very
famous founder and they're they were
discussing artificial intelligence and
the two questions were
for anyone who this particular founder
would speak to about AI he said
number one I asked them do you have kids
number two I asked them do you know how
to code and
the the do you know how to code is kind
of self-explanatory it's engineering by
bias which is understandable but the do
you have kids was to evaluate if they
are thinking sufficiently long term that
was just one of the hurdles that he
hoped people would pass and if not for
your own kids if you don't have kids
then just think about your closest
friends and their kids or their
grandkids I mean there are many ways
to look at it Ed
I so enjoy our conversations I know
we've only had two long-form
conversations thus far I hope this is is
just the second of more
and people can find you certainly online
Edwardo thorpe.com your books beat the
dealer beat the market and a man for all
markets subtitle from Las Vegas to Wall
Street how I beat the dealer and the
market
is there anything else you would like to
point people to any other
recommendations that you would like to
make requests of the audience other than
what you just requested
no I think we've covered everything
thank you
it's been a pleasure all right well
thank you so much Ed as always and for
people listening we will include
resources everything we discussed links
to all the books and Concepts and so on
at tim.blog podcast or better yet just
go to tim.blog Thorp t-h-o-r-p and we
will add as many helpful things as me
and my team can think up and call from
this interview and until next time be a
little Kinder that is necessary think
long term become a little more
interdirected learn a little bit more
about probability statistics and
mathematic I will link to that and
thanks for tuning in